guys ready back give me some room
[Music]
yeah she's a stunner I'm so proud of my
kids Heaven Kevin Hardin his ex-wife
Tory Hart's daughter shining in all her
glory as she celebrates prom with family
and friends
I'm in love with seeing my kids develop
into to people you know it's for a long
period of time you look at your kids
kids the kids right and then as they get
older and start to mature you're like
these are young adults these are these
are people as a father uh I'm sitting in
a in a in a hell of a happy chair right
now yeah over the years 18 year old
Heavens grown up alongside her Superstar
dad Kevin this is my door to Heaven hi I
love your hair bow you say hi back you
gotta say hi back hi and now she's
hitting a major Milestone here we go on
her big night Heaven wears an emerald
green gown with a split and accessorizes
with gold jewelry and strappy heels
proud dad Kevin then captions the pics
quote I have no words just pure joy my
little girl looked unbelievable
yesterday where does the time go if you
have time for what you make time for
it's all about prioritizing and uh my
kids are definitely my first priority
being a dad her mom Tori shared this
video of the beauty touching up her
makeup writing quote the most beautiful
girl in the world the family snaps
weren't complete without Heaven's photo
with her 15 year old brother Hendrix and
check out her all smiles with Kevin's
wife aniko you know why why because it's
fun we have fun no we really have a good
time Kevin who's now a father of four
shares two kids with his wife aniko
five-year-old son kinzo and two-year-old
kaori he opened up to ET back in 2015
about how fatherhood helps him keep
everything in perspective the one thing
that I want everybody to understand is
that
I live for my kids you know uh all of
the entertainment is amazing uh I'm
blessed to be doing what I'm doing but
the biggest blessing is to share
everything with my kids